je mets la main en avance je mets de la
mamma mia
nous sommes dans la classe de maternelle
de madame martin et de madame fatiha à
l'école franco jeunesse à ottawa les
deux femmes travaillent ensemble chaque
jour dans leur classe il ya 24 enfants
âgés de 4 et 5 ans fatiha c'est
l'éducatrice de la petite enfance
martine elle c'est l'enseignante où on
travaille avec à partir beaucoup de
chansons de d'histoire aussi et puis on
fait d un extrait d'aidé sont des lèvres
et le a ici les enfants apprennent des
notions de base en mathématiques en
lecture et en écriture mais toujours en
s'amusant selon madame martin
on peut s'attendre à ce qu'ils touchent
son prénom qu'ils sachent journée un peu
avec les des quantités jusqu'à 5
j'ai toujours pensé qu'être 2 ou même
plus c'est un atout pour les enfants
alors parce que ça apporte aussi un
regard supplémentaires sur ce qu'ils
font sur l'aide qui peut être apportée
c'est en 2010 que les maternelles 4,1 à
temps plein ont vu le jour en ontario un
des objectifs dépister les enfants qui
ont des problèmes le plus tôt possible
afin de les aider et de faire le suivi
ou du coup nous capables de d'éviter
d'avoir des enfants croissante les
craques parce qu'on fait de la
prévention fait des dépistages
donc il arrive beaucoup plus outillé
prêt à affronter les apprentissages
qu'ils soient en première année
aujourd'hui il ya environ deux cent
soixante mille enfants qui fréquentent
les maternelles en ontario et sans cesse
d'augmenter d'année en année parce que
c'est avantageux financièrement pour les
parents ici en ontario contrairement au
québec il n'y a pas de réseau public de
garderie ce qui fait que la facture est
salée pour les parents mais
l'implantation de ces maternelle qui se
fait graduellement sur une période de
cinq ans a été tout un défi
la province au complet c'est qu'on sait
scolaire cherchait des des personnes
qualifiées bien formés par rapport à la
petite enfance
on craignait le manque de personnel
qualifié mais aussi le manque d espace
dans les écoles les mêmes inquiétudes
qu'au québec en ce moment naturellement
il fallait regarder les écoles est ce
qu'il y avait de la place
quelle école allait commencer d'abord
est ce qu'il y avait à assez
d'enseignants il fallait travailler avec
les syndicats
il fallait être clair c'est quoi les
responsabilités de l'enseignante donald
salle de classe c kwal les
responsabilités de l'éducatrice les deux
créateurs puis une autre défi était
carrément les bâtiments des travaux
majeurs ont dû être effectués certaines
écoles ont même été agrandie au total
c'est 1 milliard 600 millions de dollars
que l'ontario est injectée pour mettre
en place les maternelles 80 en plein
huit ans plus tard le bilingue positif à
évaluer les succès qu'on vit aujourd'hui
pour les enfants on ne pourrait plus
retourner derrière on a eu le privilège
au fil des années de mesurer l'impact
d'une intervention très précoce dans la
vie des enfants peu importe leur profil
que ce soit un profil qui présentent des
besoins particuliers ou un profil tout à
fait attendre et à l'école à 6 ans on a
vu des bénéfices incroyables pour la
préparation des enfants à à leur
cheminement scolaire 1 à nantes
oui parce que tout le monde est capable
d'avoir une place c'est une garantie
garantie garantie
c'était intéressant parce qu au début il
y avait des parents qui est qui qui nous
disaient qu'ils avaient un peu peur
d'envoyer leurs enfants toute une
journée à l'école
au québec il y actuellement près de 400
classes de maternelle 4 ans à temps
plein on les retrouve surtout un milieu
défavorisé
la caq veux qu'il y en ait partout comme
en ontario à l'ordre des psychologues on
est favorable aux maternelles 4a et on a
le plus faible taux de réussite
éducative au québec
donc ça veut dire que il ya certaines
choses qu'on peut peut-être faire mieux
et dans les choses qu'on peut peut-être
faire mieux mais un des éléments si le
dépistage précoce
le gouvernement du québec se donne cinq
ans pour mettre en place des classes de
maternelle quatre ans comme celle de
madame martin
un défi de taille pour le gouvernement
et jean philippe pour rappeler que les
commissions scolaires ici dans la région
de montréal notamment ont dit c'est
impossible dans ce délai leur etc
or le ministre roberge nous le répétait
sur ce plateau il ya trois semaines
l'objectif c'est toujours partout dans
cinq ans oui effectivement il le
répétait d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
donc le gouvernement patrice qu'on dise
et va ajouter de nouvelles classes de
maternelle 4 ans dès septembre prochain
ce qu'on ne sait pas on ignore au
gouvernement est ce que ça sera par
exemple des classes encore en milieu
défavorisé ou bien on va réellement le
commencé à étendre les maternelles
quatre ans un peu partout au québec
lance claude conte l'odyssée que les
fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'éducation travaille sur le dossier on
le dit donc le gouvernement qui souhaite
implanter les maternelles quatre ans en
plein d'ici cinq ans au québec et ce
qu'on me disait également sur cet
intéressant on va s'inspirer également
du modèle ontarien parce que dans les
futures classes là que veut implanter
l'a4 patrice il y aurait à la fois une
enseignante à temps plein comme en
ontario mais on aurait également une
éducatrice à 2 mi temps comme on
retrouve lâché
chez nos voisins ontariens mais ça sera
un défi pour le gouvernement parce qu'on
si vous l'avez dit il manque de
ressources
une pénurie d'enseignants d'enseignants
mais également il ya un manque de
d'espacement glauque ou dans les écoles
alors ça ça va être tout un défi pour le
ministère effectivement très bien alors
on va suivre ça merci c'est intéressant
merci au revoir